[Music]
you've been all over the world you could
have a shop anywhere you like and yet
you're here
it doesn't terribly much matter where i
am i have my shears
what else does a man need besides the
shears
this isn't art
this is a craft
you cannot make something good
until you understand the customer
do we let all of our customers keep
black boxes in back
if we only allowed angels to be
customers soon we have no customers at
all
he says i don't want any trouble
i need you to listen carefully
there are a thousand blue boys out there
hunting for this and if they find it i
start shooting you follow making matters
worse there are a thousand racket boys
hunting for it too and if they find it
they start shooting you follow you don't
want to be involved in whatever it is
you do
you know exactly what it is that we do
well
full house tonight huh
have you ever heard of the outfit the
outfit is the network of every big-time
crew from santa monica to coney island
and tonight they sent us a message
they're hiding something my friend
[Music]
i'm gonna need that tape pal right now
why don't you try and take it gentlemen
it's gonna be a long night
sell him up
what i can't
sell him up
you need to tell me what really happened
in here tonight
now
you got five seconds to tell me what
happened open the trunk what open the
trunk and grab his arms or i'm hiding
two bodies five a number of things about
me that you don't know
four where's the tape for instance three
i'm telling you the truth
you want to survive the night
you look up dead in the eyes and you
pretend you're one of them
[Music]
you